[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima Monday  night on The Bachelor Nick vial was full  of tears again I've had amazing moments  with each and every one of you here yes  Nick cried several times though never  during a rose ceremony  Nick's pretty much done away with them  at this point just being honest with  each woman when he sends her home so I  want that with you  but I'm realizing that I don't think my  heart can get there but one woman  remains Corinne and we finally saw that  heart is gold him is platinum moment in  the flesh my heart is gold but my regime  is platinum  so Corinne tried to go all the way with  Nick but she was denied very tempting  but I've learned that are we supposed to  wait and these instances still that puts  her in the Final Four what do you think  of Nick's Final Four let me know over on  Twitter  you